eddy mitchell
et l'initiative les cieux
eddy mitchell 71 ans et toujours la
banane en vigueur
le
alors elle vous vieillissez très bien et
en général on rajoute par rapport à
johnny
c'est pas gentil claude lucien moines
convoi bonsoir bonsoir alors michel
civile et de votre manager jean
fernandez mais eddy contrairement à ce
que tout le monde croit c'est pas à
cause des dit cochrane mais à cause des
dix constanza dont vous regardiez les
films les aventures de lemmy caution
déjà le cinéma alors vous avez toujours
été chanteur dé l'époque des five rocks
même avant les chaussettes noires vous
avez déclaré le chanteur c'est celui qui
n'a pas d'ampli apporter ouais
alors 53 ans de carrière toujours la
banane si on compte en bombe de laque ça
fait combien j'ai pas je présume
regardez vous êtes toujours eu ce loupé
banane c'est incroyable vous êtes bon
vie sans moi je trouve bon ben c'est
gentil non ça je trouve pas frédéric toi
qui t'y connais
vous avez une devise eddy mitchell sait
on peut plaquer une femme mais pas ses
cheveux
bon la santé ça a l'air d'aller ça va
quand j'ai connu vous fumiez trois
paquets de clopes par jour vous buvez
une bouteille de chivas par jour et
maintenant on fait trois fois une heure
et demi jean par semaine
n'était plus bonne idée ils ont fini par
vous avoir vous aussi sur les cigarettes
quoi vous imaginez un vrai beau gars
avec un patch non non alors vous
pourriez refaire des concerts là
aujourd'hui non
alors il a décidé d'arrêter il ya deux
ans là pour le moment
obama va maintenant je dis pas le moment
va bétourné non ouais me concerne
en fait et dit a décidé d'arrêter de
faire des concerts quand son public lui
demander de chanter plus fort il
entendait rien
vous faites quand même des concerts là
vous êtes à l'île de ré la sécu un petit
concert dans un bistrot c'est plus fort
que vous
vous reconnaissez
du disque c'est sûr c'est un sosie
alors aidez vous sortez votre trente
cinquième album s'appelle rôles que vous
avez enregistré entre paris et los
angeles alors là il ya un monde de mecs
est d'abord steve cropper ah oui et
quand même le blanc de la stax c'est
celui qui accompagnait otis redding à
l'école s'est pas privé le champion
steve cropper charlie mc coy donc l
harmoniciste et bob dylan boukaert y
jones de booker si angie angie a bien
sûr voilà fait un duo avec nolwenn leroy
oui vous avez été impressionné
bien sûr oui je crée un univers elle
chante divinement bien dommage il est
l'agent du jardin ça votre album eh oui
parce que j'aurais accepté jeu j'ai fait
un exercice de style
j'avais trop l'habitude de faire de
présenter les musiciens toute la troupe
qui m'accompagnait et j'ai demandé à
jean de le faire et de la faire avec eux
parvient cette fois pas de jardin oui il
est sympa hein
alors dans le goût des larmes vous
parlez des femmes mois difficiles abbas
est une chanson de magog qui rappelle
mon enfance parce que mon jeu j'ai eu
une enfance très très heureuse mais au
niveau pognon c'était grave quoi donc le
la femme aux arrivées le 15 souvent et
donc on se serrait me coûte que dans les
vrais héros vous rendez hommage à
l'homme de la rue c'est un peu un peu
working class heroes finalement sa 1 re
re ba c'est mieux que que tous les héros
qui ont des colons maintenant
mais à l'autocollant quoi il ya beaucoup
de téléspectateurs qui appelle qui vous
demandent d'enlever votre nez parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à vous voir derrière
[Applaudissements]
bon j'ai dit ouais on va se faire une
interview tout fout l'camp d'accord et
jingle
[Applaudissements]
est ce que le rock c'était mieux avant
ah ben je rock ce s'arrêter en 59 hockey
dans le j'entends leur canal parce
qu'après il rock ah oui mais tino rossi
faisait aussi donc
l'athénée s'est tenue avant ça je sais
pas j'avais tellement connu ce alors que
la politique c'est mieux avant c'est pas
mon truc ton plus à me [ __ ] c'est
éminemment s'est pas non plus contre y'a
un truc qui est votre truc le sexe
c'était mieux avant c'était formidable
nous sommes tenus avant je préférais
j'ai vu tout à l'heure des images quand
même un peu plus flatteuse elle a raison
que l'arrêt sur le commune et
actionnant la promo c'était mieux avant
c'est bizarre parce qu'avant vos enfants
de plus de 10 ce qu'on faisait moins
maintenant on en fait beaucoup plus en
promo chantant et on voit moins de 10
des impôts c'était mieux avant bah oui
et puis séparés puis j'ai bien peur que
que ça soit pire après
est ce qu'on sait se tenir avant je sais
pas rendu parce qu'au total même temps
tellement de l'europe ouais donc on en
repère on n'est pas très français coach
mais grâce à l'envolée de santé
européens eh ben ça fait que ça fait
qu'on peut se promener
je parle pas fiscalement sam
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu